welcome back to cbs saturday morning
when someone starts powering their home
with solar energy and stops buying power
from their local utility many like to
think they've gone off the grid
but in many areas they're not as
independent as you might think many
profit from selling power back to the
community and often without covering the
cost of the maintenance of the grid
itself
now some say their sunny deal is
creating a dark cloud for others
barry peterson has the story
when i say save you say solar save
[Applause]
if you think there's nothing
controversial about the value of solar
energy
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to california yeah well anybody
who's getting such a sweet deal doesn't
want their sunshine taken away uc
berkeley professor severon borenstein
studies the economics of renewable
energy and yes this controversy is all
about money well if an industry turns
out to be not cost effective we really
need to
recognize that and find other ways to
cost effectively address climate change
when it comes to turning the sun into
electricity california leads the way
powered by laws like the one mandating
that all new homes must have solar power
but critics say owners get paid too much
for the power they sell back to the grid
and pay too little to keep the grid
maintained and upgraded a stance the
solar industry disputes so people who
have solar do they in any way contribute
to helping with the grid
well absolutely they reduce the strain
on the grid nate otto is president of
hot purple energy his company recently
installed a solar system on my palm
springs home he believes power companies
want solar users to pay much more each
month because they are losing income
to solar i believe the utilities need to
look at a different model you have the
blacksmiths
that needed to change and start making
wheels for cars
and all they wanted to do was keep
making horseshoes and so they're upset
that they're not going to make their
profit on their horseshoes
solar cells on the promise that owners
save enough money that in roughly eight
years the system will pay for itself but
keeps generating free power for decades
more
and the sales pitch works the industry
is booming solar jobs increased
167 percent over the last decade and now
employs more than a quarter million
american workers
and making solar users pay more could
make solar less attractive and some say
that would wallop the industry what does
that mean for the industry and the
people you employ
well it's going to reduce it there's
going to be some sort of industry there
it's going to be a cottage industry
rather than the growing thriving
industry that's really providing good
well-paying jobs for a lot of people
but electric companies say there's a big
problem
take my experience my electric bill
averaged about 500 a month before solar
that included money to maintain the
power grid today after spending more
than sixty thousand dollars on a solar
system it's about ten dollars with
pretty much nothing going for the grid
this is an interesting statistic mary
molin is executive director of the
california municipal utilities
association made up of non-profit power
companies he believes solar owners
should pay a monthly fee to keep the
grid going well another way to look at
it is if you own a car it's like paying
taxes for the roads if you don't pay
your taxes pretty soon the roads are
going to have potholes in them and
they're going to crumble so everybody
needs to pay their fair share of the
roads in this case everybody needs to
pay their fair share of the grid so at
the moment the solar people are getting
the car
but they're not paying for
the roads exactly
and solar owners not paying for the grid
raises rates for non-solar users who
must make up the difference many are
low-income people who can't afford solar
systems berkeley professor borenstein
all the data showed that the customers
who are putting in solar are
disproportionately wealthy and so when
customers install solar they are
generally shifting costs onto people who
are poorer than they are
and that's exactly what the reverend
frank jackson jr sees in his faith-based
community development work in southern
california a child a spoiled child you
know that's been receiving this great
allowance you know all of his life and
now at 18 it's being told that it's got
to start sharing change is hard for
everybody if you've been used to getting
this and now all of a sudden someone is
coming in and telling you you got to now
pay your fair share
like the sun the solar industry sees
more bright years ahead and with that
more debate on who pays and how much to
capture the world's freest source of
power
for cbs saturday morning barry peterson
palm
springs already you have companies that
are popping up uh that are granted
opportunities to help folks from lower
income neighborhoods and communities
afford solar power so there is like
something coming up from the other side
trying to ease that burden but you still
need to take care of the grid which i
think i think of barry's bill for in 500
to 10 what if it just went down to 75
and 65 at least goes to the grid sorry
barry not trying to make you pay more
but you know it just makes sense
absolutely it's an interesting part of
the story yeah a lot of people don't
think about when they think solar yes
good point glad we did it